lieu de mémoire sur la fameuse
guinguette du bord de seine durant la
belle époque la grenouillère a été
transformée en musée en 1990 est géré
par une association de passionnés c'est
tout naturellement qu'une exposition est
consacrée jusqu'à la fin de l'année au
célèbre peintre impressionniste pierre
auguste renoir en 1869 les artistes
peintre monet et renoir sont venus
peindre la grenouillère célèbre à cette
époque auprès des parisiens et de la
société des environs et qui venait
s'amuser monet a peint trois tableaux et
renoir en a peint trois également la
grenouillère qui attire ce même été 1869
l'empereur napoléon iii sa femme jenny
et leur fils mannequin reproductions de
tableaux coupures de journaux la plupart
des objets exposés appartiennent à
l'association les amis de la
grenouillère
la pièce centrale de l'exposition met en
avant le travail de renoir à croissy sur
seine lors de sa première visite en 1869
mais aussi en 1911 année durant laquelle
il a peint une actrice et chanteuse de
l'époque
amélie est elle là a peintes dans son
jardin de la villa qu'elle possédait à
croissy villa aux fans ce tableau que
vous voyez ici est détenue par la
fondation barnes à philadelphie à partir
des archives détenu par kroll à la
commune de croatie nous avons fait une
vitrine montrant des photos de l'actrice
dans ses costumes de scène
et puis dans les publicités qu'elle a
tourné dans la dernière salle l'univers
de la guinguette a été recréé avec des
instruments de musique
cette plongée dans l'ambiance du siècle
dernier est visible jusqu'à la fin de
l'année les mercredis et dimanches après
midi
[Musique]